and i'm brian loftis police saying that
a mother accidentally shot and killed
her three-year-old son
denise yeah this happened last night we
brought it to you
at 11 o'clock at an apartment complex in
the northeast valley on arlington street
near charleston and nellis now the
mother was supposed to
appear in court this afternoon but that
didn't happen the i-team's vanessa
murphy was in the courtroom and is
joining us now live to tell us why
vanessa
denise and brian the judge says the
mother refused to be transported to
court her bond is set at eighty thousand
dollars
you know not only is she dealing with
the loss of her
child but she's also in jail facing two
criminal charges metro police say 24
year old
jasmine vargas accidentally shot and
killed her three-year-old son
john the i-team found a twitter account
under the name
jasmine vargas along with a link to a
previous baby contest
you can see the photo there metro police
say yesterday vargas was
showing off a new gun which she had
lawfully purchased
she was with her friends in a parking
lot of an apartment complex as we
mentioned near charleston and nellis
according to an arrest report she
pointed the gun in the direction of her
son and a friend's child and pulled the
trigger
not realizing the gun was loaded the
child was shot and did not survive
police and a judge acknowledged this
appears to be an
accident but vargas again is facing two
child abuse charges
this is an incredibly serious allegation
an obviously tragic allegation this is
very
serious conduct great negligent conduct
doesn't appear to be intentional conduct
again the allegation appears to be a
mishandling of a firearm
metro police held a news conference
earlier today to announce they're seeing
too many cases like this one due to the
mishandling of guns and also because
firearms
are not being secured properly meaning
they're not locked up
so children and teens to prevent access
for children and teens
i did reach out to the child's father
the parents are not together
he declined to comment at this time
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now